In distance vector routing, each node sends
multiple distance vectors to each of its neighbors,
essentially amounting to copies of its own routing
table. Routers then compute costs to each destination
in the topology, based on shortest available path.
Distance vector routing protocols are based on the
Bellman-Ford algorithm. A node x's forwarding table is
based on the solution to the following equation.
Suppose that node x is trying to find a shortest cost route
to node y. In this case note X is trying to find a path through
some intermediate node, V, that minimizes the cost between X and
V, and the already known shortest cost path
between V and Y. Again the solution to this equation for all
destinations, Y, in the topology is X's forwarding table. Let's now
take a look at distance vector routing by way of example.